here I'll throw my favorite easy pan
fried dishes
first up pan-fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
[Music]
get a frying pan smoking hot essential
for quick pan frying
add olive oil
then season scallops with salt and
pepper starting at the top put clockwise
into the pan so you know which one to
turn first
[Music]
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cook in minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
salad Lamb's lettuce
matchsticks of Apple
seasoning
lemon zest and juice
[Applause]
[Music]
add olive oil then toss
foreign
going clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
[Music]
squeezing lemon juice and give the pan a
shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under 10 minutes my first pan
fried dish scallops with crunchy apple
salad
my next super simple pan fried recipe is
chicken and chicory and Masala sauce
[Music]
foreign
the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin side down lay
away from you to stop it all splashing
sliced chicory this versatile vegetable
can be read all white has a lovely
bitter taste and is great cooked all Raw
crush a clove of garlic and add then
sprigs of thyme
[Music]
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with a chicory
for the sauce add Masala a sweet
fortified wine from Sicily
then 150 ml of chicken stock
to make the sauce Wonder too rich and
glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in Masala sauce
[Music]
final dish cooked in The Versatile
frying pan is
Sebring with tomato and Herb salsa
[Music]
fry fillets of Sebring skin side down in
hot olive oil
if they buckle up press gently down for
perfect even cooking then season
seabream has firm white flesh perfect
for pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil
add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives and season
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combine and leave to infuse
[Music]
as the sea bream Cooks it goes opaque
when it's two-thirds from the top turn
over
[Music]
faced fry and it's done
[Music]
you bring with tomato and Herb salsa
ready in under 15 minutes
one of the keys to keeping it simple is
to prepare all the ingredients in
advance the more organized you are in
the kitchen the easier cooking becomes
here are three of my favorite quick
recipes that with a bit of advanced
preparation are so simple to make
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
starting with my easy fragrant fried
rice
first get prepped
chopped garlic ginger and chili keeping
the seeds for extra kick
slice spring onions
chopped spring greens and trim a head of
broccoli
then whisk two eggs
prep done stir fry on
add a good lug of oil to a hot pan
garlic ginger chili
next the spring greens and broccoli add
water to steam
then cook rice this dish is perfect for
using leftover rice make a well
add the eggs
spring onions
and a dash of fish sauce
[Music]
scramble then mix
season
[Applause]
top with lime and spring onions
[Music]
my fragrant fried rice made simple with
Advanced prep and ready in five minutes
my next recipe it pays to get prepped
for is garlic and saffron mayonnaise
[Music]
foreign
first get your ingredients to hand
eggs should be out of the fridge and at
room temperature
soak saffron in warm water
saffron is the most expensive spice in
the world made from the dried stigma of
crocus flowers but even a pinch gives a
fantastic taste and a wonderful color
next separate three eggs put the yolks
into a mixing bowl
Dijon mustard
finely chopped garlic
the drained saffron
and a squeeze of lemon and then mix
whisking constantly add oil slowly it
won't take forever
for perfect flavor use half olive oil
and half vegetable oil
where the mayonnaise comes together
season
[Music]
smooth thick consistency means it's done
top with saffron
Rich delicious and perfect with
everything from Seafood to sandwiches
and chips my second recipe
garlic and saffron mayonnaise easy to
get right as long as you've planned
ahead
my final dish that's a stinch to cook
with a little Advanced prep work is
mussels with celery and chili
[Music]
first prep the veg chop spring onions
shallots
a clove of garlic
and chili to taste
then thinly sliced celery
at a bay leaf and Thyme veg ready
[Music]
add oil to a pan and Fry
[Music]
season
then add mussels and stir
muscles were my favorite shellfish cheap
healthy and delicious
cover and steam for a couple of minutes
as the muscles open add vermouth and
aromatic 45 wine
[Music]
and 150 ml of dry white wine
on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a source
discard any mussels that are still shut
[Music]
then finish with Creme Fraiche and
chopped parsley
[Music]
minimal prep and cooked in less than 10
minutes my muscles were celery and chili
impressive affordable and super speedy
cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes and
cherries and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice Anchovies and
garlic
[Music]
dried chilies great for keeping the
cupboard to add a hit of heat on demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and Fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
chopped black olives and salted Capers
cook to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great store-covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain add to the sauce with a splash of
the water it's full of starch which
gives a great silky consistency
then season with pepper and top with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chilies
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soak Chipotle chilies in hot water these
are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
together and season
foreign next fry corn on the cob in
olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
fantastically messy to eat grilled corn
with Chipotle chili butter and utterly
delicious Smoky treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade first Scotch bonnet chilies
they may be small but pack real heat and
a fruity punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
three different chilies
three amazing flavors
three irresistible dishes